all right biggest upsets so far in free
agency in honor of march madness shireen
give me one
i'm gonna go with the patriots mike i
mean we knew they had a lot of money
right i think they were third entering
free agency with the most money but i
didn't think they would spend quite like
they've spent and i read the day and i
read somewhere i think it was on
bleacher report that they've spent the
second most money in free agency and hit
in the history of free agency and
they've designed players left and right
and to get the two tight ends johnnu
smith and then to come back the next day
and get hunter henry
was really
a surprise but just surprised me the
approach they took they've been one of
the oldest rosters in the nfl over the
last few seasons they're going to be one
of the oldest rosters in the nfl
this season too but it also tells you
mike that they have swung and missed on
some of those draft picks they've traded
down a lot they've drafted low and they
haven't drafted real well
which is why they've had to go out in
free agency doesn't work very often work
for the bucks last year we'll see if it
works with patriots this year
and shereen something occurred to me
yesterday when sims and i were talking
about this it's not just failure to
draft well it's failure to develop young
players and i wonder how much
impatience shines through
with belichick when you've got these
guys who don't know where the hell
they're supposed to be what the hell
they're supposed to do how the hell
they're supposed to do it does he have
limited patience for guys who just don't
have the light come on and does he does
he gravitate toward veterans who know
what they're supposed to do and i could
see bill you what a shock bill belichick
is a guy who doesn't have a lot of
patience for dumb all you have to do is
watch one of his press conferences and
you come to the conclusion quickly he's
got no patience whatsoever for people
who don't know what they're supposed to
do and how they're supposed to do it he
doesn't want to have to tell you what to
do he'd rather have someone who gets it
and i think he comes to quick judgments
with these young players as to whether
or not they actually get it i was
surprised by
and we were on the air the other day
when this happened peter king and i on
pftpm tyrod taylor to houston because
that was and this was before even i
think the first
of the desean watson assault allegations
but the tyrod taylor the houston move
told me that the texans recognized they
needed to do something it was the first
acknowledgment that they were accepting
the predicament they were in whether it
meant
they were going to trade deshaun watson
or use tyrod taylor as the backup or the
guy who takes over if deshaun watson
doesn't show up
and now he may be the guy who ends up
playing because deshawn watson is on the
commissioner exempt list but uh which is
a possibility as this thing continues to
unfold
that surprised me that surprised me
because it was the first acknowledgement
that the texans understand
the mess that they're in
yeah i think it spoke the most more than
any press conference that they've held
mike that that they are looking to the
possibility of not having deshawn watson
when they start the season whether it's
a holdout or whether they trade him or
however this thing plays out
they may not have him this season and
they know that and they're going with
the bridge quarterback if they don't
have him and tyrod taylor which we know
he's been good at that role right we saw
it with baker mayfield and cleveland and
with justin herbert and with the
chargers and and he's been in several of
those situations throughout the years
and has handled that very well mike
give me another one that uh you would
call an upset for the first few days of
free agency
well i love i i think they've had the
best offseason of any team and that's
the tampa bay buccaneers and i love when
you can keep your own free agents you
know what you have in them and you're
able to keep your own i didn't think
they'd be able to do it i didn't think
they would be able to keep shaq barrett
and chris godwin much less gronkowski
ryan suckup levante david they've done
it they've put the band back together
and even if they don't get leonard
fournette or ab back which we think they
could get those two guys back because we
haven't heard anything about them on the
free agent market even if they don't get
those guys back it's been a highly
successful off season for the buccaneers
and if i'm going to vegas i'm putting my
money down on them to win another super
bowl mike yeah you know another topic
that came up the other day peter said
hey just because you're keeping these
guys together doesn't mean that you're
going to win another championship i mean
there hasn't been a repeat since the
2003 2004 patriots but from my
perspective
the key guy who's back is tom brady and
even if they had some turnover with some
of these guys brady will do what he has
to do to get everyone on the same page
because for him it's not about winning
number two it's about winning number
eight it becomes easier if you have the
continuity you don't have to break in
new personalities but but i also do
think there is value
and now there's more value i think with
another team than there would be with
these buccaneers there's value in
finding a veteran player
who doesn't have a ring who wants one
because that can give you that extra
little kick that extra little thing to
avoid complacency shireen and i i i
yesterday and this was i'll tie this
together my other surprise was aj green
to the cardinals because that slams the
door on i think larry fitzgerald
returning to the cardinals because
you're going to have four receivers who
don't play special teams on game day if
you've got fitzgerald on the roster with
green and christian kirk and deandre
hopkins and you got too much money tied
up in your in your receiver room if
you're giving green up to eight and a
half million what are you going to pay
larry fitzgerald you paid him 11 million
last year so what if larry fitzgerald
decides to go play for the buccaneers
for a year and take the antonio brown
spot on the depth chart and they let
brown go somewhere else
that would be something you get a guy
out there with the man of the year patch
on his jersey a guy with the the
gravitas that larry fitzgerald has and
you and you add that
burning desire he has and the clue for
me was when he said in november if the
cardinals win the super bowl hill retire
and we're like well you're gonna play
forever then and i know the cardinals
are trying but
they're not a super bowl contender but
to me that was the acknowledgement
implicit by fitzgerald that maybe he
does one final year
with a team that is a super bowl
contender it's not like he's going to
burn bridges in arizona he's he's spent
more than enough time in arizona i can't
imagine a single cardinals fan being mad
at him and uh fitzgerald finished his
career with uh a team like the chiefs or
the buccaneers
yeah it surprised me too mike and i had
that on my list of surprises when we
started making the list because it did
signal the end of larry fitzgerald in
arizona now maybe he's already told him
he's going to retire but that doesn't
also preclude him from unretiring and
coming back and going to the buccaneers
at some point
say after training camp or whatever i
think the bucks are going to be just
like they were last year they're going
to add some of these guys before the
season starts into training camp and the
first week of the season like they did
this past year because they're going to
want to play at tampa they're going to
want to try to win a super bowl and they
know tom brady knows how to do that
better than anyone else in the league
mike
yeah and as as more and more of these
guys who have been cut or who have
become free agents don't get what they
thought they were going to get that's
when it becomes attractive to go chase
a ring
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports